every day Planned Parenthood workers
serve more than 8,000 people in more
than 600 clinics across the country in
2016 nearly two and a half million
people turned to the organization for
health care this came amid increased
scrutiny of its leadership in the
political arena beginning today those
responsibilities fall to Lena when who
takes over as Planned Parenthood's new
president she was previously Baltimore's
health commissioner and she's here only
on CBS this morning
good morning doctor how are you I'm
doing well it's my first day on the job
and you're with us so you're the first
doctor to lead this organization in half
a century
what what do you plan to bring to the
organization from your background well
this is deeply personal to me I was a
patient of Planned Parenthood and so as
my mother and my sister just like one in
five women in America and as a doctor I
am proud to lead our organization as we
deliver life-saving care to two and a
half million people every year
why did your family use Planned
Parenthood when we first came to this
country my mother didn't have health
care anywhere else and Planned
Parenthood was there for her just as
it's there for women across the country
to provide cancer screenings to provide
birth control we do more to prevent
unintended pregnancies every year than
any other organization did you have any
trepidation you're the mother of a 14
month old baby Elijah you are still a
practicing emergency room physician it
has now become such a political
politicize in such a controversial job
did you have any trepidation about
taking it being a parent has clarified
my values and what I want to do is to
shape the future for my son Eli and it's
a future where all people are treated
the same that all people have the right
to health care and where it's a society
where we trust women and we trust all
people to make the best decisions for
themselves in their bodies so were you
encouraged after the elections yes and
no on the one hand we saw people rise up
women people of color rise up to speak
in favor of reproductive rights and
access to healthcare but on the other
hand less than 24 hours after the
elections
the Trump administration came out with
new rules that would prevent employers
or actually that would allow employers
to deny women birth control coverage I
can't believe it's 2018 and we're still
debating birth control
imagine if we're having the same
conversation about vasectomies or about
insulin women's health care is health
care and health care shouldn't be
political well it is your first day at
the job but you are familiar with the
Trump administration as health
commissioner in Baltimore you've sued
this administration twice and one given
that this is a president who seems to
hold grudges and and as personal
reactions to people directly how do you
plan on working with this administration
going forward I come to this work as a
doctor and not a politician I'll work
with anyone who wants to expand access
to health care for me it's deeply
personal I treated a woman who waited
more than a year before she had a lump
in her breast examined and by the time
she got treated it was too late and
metastatic cancer and she died not long
after I saw her leaving behind three
young children for me that's what it's
about it's about saving people's lives
that's the work that we've done a
Planned Parenthood for over 100 years
and I'm proud to keep on providing
health care and protecting access to
that care doctor you said becoming a
mother clarified your values so many
people I've talked to who want to
restrict abortion rights said Parenthood
clarified their values and that's why
they want to restrict abortion rights
what do you tell those people who have
the same parent based authenticity to
their beliefs that you claim I respect
each person's beliefs for themselves my
problem is if they want to impose their
own beliefs on other people as a
physician I'm trust my patients my job
is to give medically accurate
information to my patients and allowed
them to make the best choices about
their health I don't think that
politicians have any role to play in the
exam room in determining people's
personal medical decisions
I trust women let's been hacked let's
talk about what's been happening at the
ballot box in the midterm elections you
had seven more governors who are pro
abortion rights were elected but there
were also anti-abortion measures that
passed in the states of Alabama and West
Virginia Alabama specifically became the
first
state in the nation to inaccurate
opponents caller personhood clause in
its constitution West Virginia became
the first state to approve a measure
stripping the state constitution of any
abortion rights restrictions including
an issue about Medicaid funding what's
happening in the state's
we're seeing mixed results and we are
seeing people rise up in record numbers
in favor of women's health care we have
more than 25 governors now who are Pro
women's health we're also seeing solidly
red states like Utah Idaho and Nebraska
vote in favor of Medicaid expansion
which indicates that people want more
health care not less and I strongly
believe as a physician that health care
has to be a fundamental human right and
that women's health care is health care
so is this argument that Roe versus Wade
is going to be overturn is that
hyperbole there is a very real
likelihood that Roe vs. Wade could be
overturned in this Supreme Court which
would leave 25 million women which is a
third of women of reproductive age in
this country and without access to
reproductive rights not roe versus wade
itself but essentially some other case
that comes through that restricts
abortion rights well there are 15 cases
right now that are just one step away
from the Supreme Court and in the last
seven years there have been 400 laws
passed in different states that directly
restrict women's access and I am deeply
concerned about this from a public
health perspective right well your first
day on the job you got a lot of work it
seems thank you so excited to do it I
can tell thank you for coming dr. lee
hwon thank you